hey everyone
for those that don't know in high level
perception
i chapter 5
inclusive stakeholding i
published a project called rich patrons
to go along with that chapter
in my effort to inclusively
stakehold and biomimic
mycorrhizal networks
and maximize the unleashing
of everyone's gifts on the planet
and so this is my effort to do so
and there are a lot of other efforts
that are going on to do so
and there is a massive crowdsourcing of
ideas that's happening before the
united states's 250th birthday in 2026
which is being this
meme of inclusive stakeholding was first
planted the seed and watered in my
consciousness by joon yoon
and he also prior to that planted the
seed of interdependent capitalism
i highly recommend reading those two
books by him and his family
and his foundation so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to unpack rich patrons
and i will hopefully be able to
communicate
why we need to unlock the
six to ten trillion dollars that's
currently
locked up in ultra high net worth
families and put that into
the teams that
are tackling the biggest challenges in
the world so that we can also get
past all of the impending
fermi filters especially given the fact
that we are in the ai age
so let's do this rich patrons inclusive
stakeholding art
science spirit and philanthropy all
right
the first thing that i do on rich
patrons is i make an analogy
the analogy that i make is between the
house of medici in the past and
mr beast in the present so in the past
we had the medici family where textile
traders and innovative bankers who
financed the invention of the piano and
opera
they funded the construction of saint
peter's basilica and the florence
cathedral
they patron leonardo da vinci
michelangelo and raphael the trinity of
great masters of the renaissance
also patroning galileo botticelli
machiavelli brunesheli among many others
in the arts and culture
they are the quintessential example of
wealth acquisition followed by
investment into unleashing the full
potential of art and humanism
all right and now in the present with mr
beast jimmy donaldson aka mr beast is
pioneering the archetype of youtube
philanthropy
where he and his team produce fun family
friendly games and challenges for the
subscribers to win thousands of dollars
gifts range from cash to cars houses
electronics and more
much is donated directly to people in
need he is the fastest growing youtuber
because he is combining entertainment
with philanthropy
many content creators are now applying
the strategy to grow in influence
inclusive stakeholding is an inevitable
pivot for our future
really important analogy to draw there
the most successful
mimetics of our future are going to be
the ones that are blatantly
in service to other and then
fueling whatever resources they gain
from that process
right back into it so not self dealing
but really bio mimicking
all right and then i jump into this
really profound quote by andrew carnegie
the rich should use their wealth to help
enrich society
and that's from the gospel of wealth and
he was one of the most
influential
wealthy advocates for
philanthropy so there's approximately
six to ten trillion dollars
locked up in ultra high net worth
individuals and families and that's
those who own assets of 30 million plus
us dollars
and the number one reported issue from
families is the lack of trust that their
patronage
philanthropy will be used honestly
we provide that trusted outlet with the
world's best teams
alright and here are the patron options
in the usa so again
we're unlocking the money and we're
funneling it into these
best highest level teams across the
planet to tackle these biggest issues
so here are the patron options in the
u.s rare disease
the biotech revolution is among us but
poor incentive structures prevent
investment into tackling rare diseases
from cpt-1a which prevents the body from
burning fat once glycogen is depleted
to rare clusters of disease that even
world renowned doctors failed to solve
until the introduction of hemp cbd
our scientists are looking for one
million dollars to continue cataloging
and solving rare diseases for all
affected worldwide
consciousness what is the nature of
consciousness what does it have to do
with who we
are and why we are here we have several
teams doing research on theories
gathering the most brilliant minds in
the space and maximizing well-being by
reducing unnecessary suffering through
proven techniques and unleashing the
innate peace and joy of being
schools teachers have been doing their
best educating new generations
given the growing population and pace of
technology new models that follow the
child
are rapidly spreading providing novel
curricula leveraging everything from the
socratic method to artificial
intelligence
a great example is our friends at
academy of thought and industry who are
looking to expand into more cities in
the usa
all right three more options
community although moving to metro areas
remains favorable for young people
the areas they are leaving behind are
experiencing a resurgence and
specialization gearing up for the tech
age
from social impact accelerators and
innovation collectives to academies for
heretical thinkers
our teams have systematized unleashing
creativity in dozens of cities across
the us
inspiring long-term thinking about what
more beautiful inclusive future we want
to architect
robotics in preparation for the ai age
youth around the world are learning how
to engineer robots to complete
objectives on playing fields
this has been systematized by one of our
partner organizations first robotics
who has a fast growing charter in the
bay area called playing at learning
supporting children in the us to learn
these skills prevents them from entering
careers that face automation
this combination of learning while
playing is key
art one of the most under appreciated
and
represented of all career paths and
modernity is art
yet it is a major key for meaning
inspiration and divinity
we are fixing this de-sacralization with
re-architecting incentives to support
local artists
especially those with moonshot projects
like crowdsourcing to give gigantic
pieces of art between countries and new
perennial spiritual temples
that provide spaces in the us for
communion with higher purpose
and anytime you click on this get
involved button on the screen it will
take you directly to
rich patrons at gmail dot com which
anybody can
inquire whether you're one of the
families that want to get involved
of ultra high net worth or whether
you're an organization that wants to
list yourself
on rich patrons all right rich patrons
globally
this is the patron options on the global
level
entrepreneurs across the world
entrepreneur creativity is being
hindered by unnecessary frictions
this molasses usually arises as corrupt
governments tyrannical laws and service
to self dynamics that result in ideas
never being executed
our friend might wade is eradicating
these issues into car senegal by
unlocking free markets to overcome
poverty and we are looking to do the
same in other areas worldwide
mental health early interventions to
prevent trauma drastically augment life
trajectories
we are helping youth and adults quickly
rebound from major stress as well as
erad
educate to avert it all together in both
kenya with our partner tom okumu osborne
and in israel with our friends over at
wisdom increasing worldwide efficiency
with overcoming
life challenges to actualize gifts by
leveraging technology and mentorship
idealism our friends dr bernardo castro
and fred matzer with their essentia
foundation in the netherlands are
mainstreaming metaphysical idealism in
order to bring people together around
how conscious experience is fundamental
to well-being
and fundamental to being we believe by
coming
at reality from this perspective we can
better bridge science with spirituality
and tackle the biggest challenges
humanity faces
three more morphic fields what is the
field around a flock of birds or school
of fish how are they communicating with
each other to move so flawlessly as a
cohesive whole
what about human social fields our
friends dr rupert
sheldrake and his team in the uk are
conducting experiments on joint
attention and telephone telepathy aiming
to
prove their planted flags beyond the
edge of knowledge
we are also looking for five hundred
thousand dollars to build a mobile
application to test morphic residents in
a game-based style with youth
lineage preservation our economic
machinery brought us great flourishing
but has come with tremendous downsides
that we must solve
including the displacement of millions
of indigenous people and their wisdom
traditions
which are oozing with knowledge
paramount for modernity to embody
we have local teams working on the kogi
lineage in sierra nevada de santo
marta in colombia and the tibetan
buddhist lineage in tibetan india with
ethnographic condensation hastening
we must act quickly to preserve
entheogens anthogen means unleash the
divine within
there is nothing more important than
each of us unlocking our unique
communion with reality and unleashing
our gifts to the world
the assistance of plant medicines animal
secretions and synthetics have healed
veterans reversed orphan diseases and
teenagers and are slowly becoming
decriminalized in developed countries
unlocking whole new waves of
enlightenment to come
support our teams doing this work
globally
okay so now i'm going to give you some
other options so rich patrons
do not only have to participate on
a monetary level they have to
participate on a real estate level they
have the option to
and this means according to ubs there
are that's union bank switzerland there
are 225 000 ultra high net worth
worldwide
who each own on average three to four
homes
if you'd like to share your unused
properties to house our teams
we have trusted channels to do so this
can act as an alternative or complement
alongside giving direct monetary
patronage our teams keep properties in
exceptional condition
we are flexible with time periods and
notices hoping to both get you involved
in this
next wave of inclusive stakeholding and
more easily provide the basic needs for
unleashing creative gifts to so many
worldwide
should they have the option you have the
option as rich patrons to
get involved on a housing level and on a
monetary level or one of the two
but the teams and the most creative
artistic
entrepreneurial scientific minds
spiritual minds on the planet also
need this assistance with all the unused
properties
let them live there
level of involvement some ultra high
network choose to give anonymously
which we of course precisely respect
others have chosen to actively partake
in their patronage and even become
friends with our teams
families will occasionally ask for
sponsor recognition or to patron our
catalog rather than specific options
we accommodate many of these variants
out of all these combinations of
involvement the choice is up to you
all right and this breaks down the
decoupling of real gdp per capita and
median male income which happened in
1971
and clearly exclusive stakeholding
became most pronounced after 1971 when
median male income decoupled from real
gdp per capita in the usa
while our ultra high now with friends
and globalizers became extravagantly
wealthier 50
of americans can't afford a sudden 500
crisis bill actions have reactions in
this case what transpired for 50 years
has been
causing destabilizing downstream effects
on the psyche of our general populace
inclusive stakeholding reverses these
tumultuous issues where everyone is
uplifted
similar to mycorrhizal networks enabling
exchanges of carbon nutrients and water
between trees fungi implants
economic biomimicry scientists used
isotope tracing to discover a miraculous
underground two-way interdependent
resource highway
it wasn't just large tree sharing
nutrients but they even got back
nitrogen and phosphorus which are vital
for their growth
it's obvious our forced ecosystems are
an ideal model for us to follow
a simple effort of economic biomimicry
solves this worrisome issue for humans
people who become stakeholders and
collective in the collective ship we are
building and steering take that
financial success and pour it into their
family education health wellness
business artistry and prosperity
further perpetuating economic growth
the pioneers over the last several years
dr june has been relentlessly pursuing
inspiring people to rethink society's
architectures through the lens of
evolutionary biology
it's paramount for us to extend our
inclusive values from our local village
to the entire world
in interdependent capitalism inclusive
stakeholding june and his family outline
a multitude of frameworks
we are implementing to make this
transition of which rich patrons is one
from medici to mr beast the emergence of
a service to other cultures zeitgeist
has been protruding through the veil of
normalcy via myriad uncommon leaders
over the centuries
today's internet and tomorrow's ai
generation are hungry for a way to fully
unleash the unique gifts of every soul
inclusive stakeholding with rich patrons
does exactly this pick among our teams
and projects
plus your level of involvement and get
on board early with a trusted partner in
this modern renaissance
and that's it and you can click get
involved there
or up here under the
global or under the usa or at the very
top
up here as well so that's
in essence what rich patrons is again we
are very
simply just trying to biomimic the
mycorrhizal networks and the wisdom
within them
and we want to architect civilization
given decentralization technologies
in a way that follows that so we are a
trusted outlet
for unlocking the six to ten trillion
dollars in ultra high net worth
families and individuals that their
number one reported issue is to not have
that trusted outlet
and what we will be doing is we will be
continuing
to invest that money whether it's ten
thousand five thousand
fifty thousand twenty five thousand a
hundred thousand seventy five thousand
a million however much we're given we're
able to
dedicate directly to these teams and
projects across the planet in a
very trusted way and then the level of
involvement
of the rich patrons get to pick how much
they want to be involved if they want to
be completely anonymous if they want to
be involved a little bit if they
want brand recognition all of these
types of things
and then in doing so we maximize
the success of things like the
sustainable developmental goals we
maximize the success of
all of our creative fruits being
unleashed into the world period
so that's the essence of rich patrons
it's
part of high level perceptions
chapter 5 on inclusive stakeholding and
this is that
mycorrhizal symbiosis
and then this is another massive reason
why giving the ai
age that we have to blooms two sigma we
have to reach down and help people that
are in the crosshairs of automation of
software and hardware
upscale their labor into more rube
goldberg
style ways of creativity genius that
happens once
all right so that's it thanks for tuning
in to this bit on rich patrons
check out the link in the bio below and
also
put this in front of the people that
need to see it put this in front of both
the ultra high net worth people around
the planet that need this
that need to see this even those are
just a couple thousand or a couple tens
of thousands of dollars that want to
invest it somewhere that's a trusted
outlet
we are that trusted outlet we have the
world's most brilliant scientists
engineers artists spiritual leaders that
are working on these different projects
that have already had great success in
these fields
that need that little bit more fuel
under their ass
and so if you want to contribute
monetarily or with your home
with your home that you don't use at all
every year
i hear of more and more people as i
climb up the hierarchy that tell me that
yeah we have properties we don't even
stay there
at all throughout the year it's like
open up that property
right now to people that are trusted
that are vetted
for them to come and live there so they
can actualize their gifts into the world
because we all desperately need them and
they don't need the overhead
pressures of needing to
instantly be making money in the economy
and that's what's holding back so many
people's gifts right now
and also share it with people not only
the ultra high net worths but also those
artists entrepreneurs scientists
engineers spiritual leaders
those people that want a place for them
to be
able to put themselves out there
we have many other projects that are
unlisted on this website
that are in a catalog that the rich
patrons can choose from so if you want
to be a part of that catalog we will vet
you
reach out again that's rich patrons at
gmail dot com so
reach out to us much love let's bio
mimic mycorrhizal networks
let's maximize human potential
let's unlock those trillions of dollars
and put them to good use
around the planet of meeting the basic
needs of people and unleashing their
full
gifts tackling the sdgs i love you very
much
thank you for tuning in we got this much
love
peace